- I feel like a lot of their
liquors have snakes in them.
- Hopefully this isn't,
like, The Hangover II,
which was incredibly disappointing.
- I'm probably going to throw up.
- If it has alcohol, I'm going to like it.
- I will probably dislike it.
(Thai music)
- Cheers, welcome to Thailand.
- Welcome.
- Smells Christmasy.
- It's sour.
- Weird, yeah, weird.
- That's fucking delicious.
- It's nice.
I don't even know if it's alcohol.
I could drink this on the beach.
- Powerade?
- So you just get people boozed up
as soon as they step off the plane?
This is why people like Thailand so much.
- I know!
(Thai music)
- Singha?
- [Man Off Camera] Yeah.
- Ah-Ha, ah-ha-ha, ah-ha-ha.
I think that's what I'm supposed to do.
- Maybe it makes you sing.
(operatic singing, laughing)
- It smells like a garage after you've
played beer pong in it for a while.
- This tastes like
freshman year of college.
Just pretending I like it.
- It's a little more like
(smacking) Miller High Life.
- Leinenkugel.
- Oh, this is like beer pong beer.
(popping noise)
- You throw it.
Who cares if you have,
like, little leaves in it.
(Thai music)
- This looks fancy.
- These are the ones that scare me.
(whimpering)
- I'm scared of it.
- (Mocking) I'm scared.
- What is this?
- Is it celery?
- Is this an animal?
- Is this lemongrass?
- Smells like it could cut through stuff.
- Smells like a Vegas hotel.
- Oh Mylanta.
- It's great.
- I hate that.
(spits out drink, laughing)
- Miami.
- Yeah, this feels like
a vacation-ass drink.
- Spring Break, Vegas.
- What is this again?
Thai chili pepper.
- Take a big bite.
It's really not that hot.
(chomping, ominous music)
- That's great.
- That's terrible!
- Ow, my eyeball!
- Honestly, just breathe in the drink.
It's like...
- Whoa!
(laughing)
- Ding ding ding ding!
Oh my God! (coughing)
Oh!
Welcome to Thailand.
Ai yi yi, whoa, Neal.
What the fuck?
- Is this an accepted part of the date,
where you're both just like, "Hold on!"
(intense exhaling)
(laughing, crying)
- I'm crying.
- No, that's going to be just as bad.
(whimpering)
(Thai music)
- I'm just connecting the dots.
The bad guy in Hangover, his name's Chang.
- Was Chang.
(smacking)
- Oh!
- Huh.
- Maybe Hangover II was a
little better than I thought.
- (Mumbling) Nope.
- Hangover II wasn't that great.
- Some kind of like a
sweet, little caramel.
(exhaling, ominous music)
- My lips hurt so bad.
I can't concentrate.
- You know, we're fine,
we're fucking fine.
- Oh, do you have milk?
- It's like, all right,
you're at your mom's house.
You're going to go pee.
She has this little potpourri dish.
You accidentally hit it.
It falls into the toilet after you pee,
and then someone's like,
"I'll give you five bucks to drink that,"
and you're like, "All right."
Is that potpourri and pee?
- Oh!
- I believe so!
- I'm trying to find an American beer.
This is kind of like a Heineken.
- Lumon, or, like, a shakta.
- Minor Heineken, a Meineken.
- This is Budweiser.
- Nothing, because we haven't
made anything this bad.
- Thailand, we're not just a party town.
(Thai music)
- Oh no, oh no!
My butthole just tightened up.
It's not loose or anything.
(gagging)
- Yeah, you take it as a shot.
Come on, it's a shot glass, right?
- Ooh, it's sweet.
It's like molasses.
- Like nail polish remover.
- Yeah.
- It didn't really have a taste to it,
but I don't know if that's because, like,
I don't have a tongue any more.
- This is exactly when you turn 20,
and you've saved up to
go over to Thailand,
and you're just going to go over there and
not remember the whole goddamn trip,
but you're going to come back and be like,
"I found myself."
- My mom doesn't know that I drink,
and so she's hella disappointed right now.
(laughing)
- Well, I'm nice and drunk.
- What a rollercoaster of emotions, huh?
- The one with the chili
pepper, that's my favorite.
- The one that destroyed you?
- I think it was a good experience.
- Dumb Yankee bit the pepper.
Ha ha, internet!
You got me.
- My favorite was the pepper drink,
until it turned against me and went mad.
- Mom, I'm sorry.
You know what's up, and I'm over 21.
- Give me some of that!
- Mm-Hmm, wow.
- It's like heaven.
- God, isn't it, though?